well everybody
bet you didn't expect to see us here
again
but the good news is or let's it's very
exciting to introduce our new co-host
my
mom thank you thank you thank you
[Applause]
i bend but i i can't the table's in the
way
oh right well you want to stand up and
you can stand up and back all right if
that's what you feel like doing
yeah
[Applause]
you know
stand up donna
um you know
we're like listen
just take a few letters out swap some
things around families
it's bad it's practically it's it's an
upgrade it's a piece of cake it's a
piece of cake it's a peace and love
mom how are you feeling about being the
new host of families well i feel good
and i feel very fresh with my teddy
fresh shirt on i don't know i it this is
going to be fun yeah well the people
were very smitten by you after your
call-in oh my god last week
we all my technical
difficulties
yeah but it's not you it's kind of it's
just boomer it's boomer stuff yeah do
you know what a boomer is
a baby boomer yeah yeah you know what it
means though
yeah
yeah
well i know that they refer to it after
the war you know we all these people
had babies right that's
we boomed
but do you know what it means if i say
oh like for example dad you're such a
boomer or i would say more like dan
you're such a boomer so basically we're
technically challenged yes you got it
right on
it's not just that it's a whole thing of
things but today we're gonna see
amongst other things who is the boomer
we're gonna play who's the boom oh god
that would be me well we'll see don't
count yourself out
um i want to say at the top of the show
this thursday 10 a.m ela has been
working overtime to bring you the most
comprehensive well-designed teddy fresh
dot
collection this is one of them
beautifully digitally printed floral
design teddy fresh hey
teddyfresh.com dad come over here and
show
this is another one my dad is like um
oh my god come over here look at this
he's a male model look at this full
terry cloth shirt and shorts he is out
there big pimping dude
what a slick outfit
careful with your arm oh yeah i got a
new shoulder okay yeah
don't mess up your shoulder yeah with
the hat my dad just got a brand new
shoulder he's out here well you know
don't do that
teddyfresh.com june 2021 collection you
got the florals for women and men
you got the hoodies
you got the
sweatpants you got the more hoodies you
got the more sweatpants what else you
got you got the tank top i've got the
tank top you like it i love it oh good
review from my mom and where are you at
okay this is the hottest shirt that is
cool camp shirt this is like high-end
designer don't even get me started gary
did you see that
can dad have one dad can have one yeah
i'm waiting for mine so get in line
zach got his before mine i'm like yo
what's going on here
i know zack and a.b all cruising around
in my favorite chair i was like where's
mine
that's really that was really uh this is
what my dad was modeling the terry oh
powder with the tf yes
nice
oh this one dad you may want this one it
says
it's embroidered it says my dad wears
teddy fresh and actually it's true in
this
case uh we got a one a nighty shirt i
don't know if you're into that oh
oh we got one more image here i don't
have any pajamas that would
and finally oh
so this is really it's a dip dye down
the center it's not the greatest photo
to show it off
but head on over to teddyfresh.com if
you want to check it out all right let's
start the show
i get stopped all the time by people
saying oh i love your your teddy fresh
love that i know
anything you want to say before we jump
into our first segment here
um
well
i'm gonna have to get used to this thing
my mom said she feels like she has a
penis in her face
before we started
i know it's really very it's a
microphone well i can use it to scratch
my nose right okay or your hand oh my my
it's about the right size
louise hey if yours looks like mine it
ain't
and trust me that that's how it works i
think
maybe not
all right can we slick this guy
seriously okay anything non-penis
related you want to talk should we
should we talk about families
can we can we talk about father's day
sure
what do you got to say well it's
regarding your son go ahead i'd love to
hear what you have to say okay well
teddy
ethan's two-year-old son
has got his sense of humor
right and
i was just telling
dad about
when i wanted ethan was
about i don't know eight nine years old
and i wanted to get a group shot of
jessica and ethan
and sean on on our couch and i had the
three of them i had you three guys you
were in the middle
sit down and i had my camera
and just as i was about to take the
picture you put your your the soles of
your feet on the couch your knees were
up you pulled your pants down you spread
your cheeks i took the picture of your
butt bung hole
and and that's a word i haven't heard in
a while
i couldn't i went oh my god ethan that
it was so you and then and then at
father's day
was it you that asked teddy what he was
gonna have for dinner and he said poop
yeah yeah he started telling the guy his
aunt jessica that jessica is uh ethan's
oldest sister
laughed so hard there were tears running
down her eyes it was like oh my god
another ethan well i don't know when he
started doing or like where he got that
from but i go usually when i come home
from the office i go theodore how was
your day what did you eat for lunch and
he goes poop
where did that come from he starts
laughing and now he goes poop poop
and he's laughing yep the showing my
butthole i don't remember that but
you guys show me that picture all the
time oh my god
yes
i wish someone would just throw that
photo i don't need to see my little kid
balls and
penis and everything i was so distracted
just all balls and butthole and it's
just a lot
well you were you were
focused on your humor
duty jokes well that's true the apple
doesn't the uh
the the poop doesn't fall far from the
butthole
all right you ready for our first
segment mom
yes okay here this one's for you okay
it's called how well do you know your
son
oh
that's this should be interesting
because i've i've said here before
that i feel like you don't know any of
my preferences that's what dad says
we've only been married 47 years and he
says you still don't know me
for example you will ask me
up until the very day i left the house
how i liked a certain dish just like you
would ask do you like i don't know
tomatoes on it and i've never wanted
they're mine no that's not how people
work well you never know you want
tomatoes on it after 20 years of me
saying no wait you don't like tomatoes
well i'm just using eggs oh okay
all right fine all right let's see how
well anyway that's the thing i know yeah
put it to the test okay okay
watch i'll get everything right okay
well that would surprise me
okay ready i'm ready what is my favorite
food
pasta
pizza pizza
i thought that was a softball but pasta
is actually the one food that i vocally
said i don't like really why why do you
think i like time i never eat pasta
you're always making it for the family
for elon and theodore but not for myself
i don't like pasta you don't can i
i'm in trouble
go ahead yes yeah thai food
no it's pizza you guys gotta be picky am
i right i would have accepted pizza or
hamburger
oh okay yeah maybe
i usually we used to stop at all the
fast food stores remember that's how i
used to bribe you to go shopping that i
would get you um a corn dog yeah i have
trauma from you guys basically just
feeding me fast food all the time
i talked to my therapist about that
really
i don't i don't remember maybe i god
well i was craving that when i was
pregnant with you so
you think i was destined to be fat
because you ate well i don't know if you
were destined to be fat but you were
destined to like fast food it's a curse
that i uh still carry to this day but
pasta is actually probably the wrongest
answer
you could have given so okay let's try
the next question hey i'm in trouble who
was ethan's best friend growing up kyle
that's true yes
that's an easy one though i feel like
because our families were right really
okay i'll give that one to you okay
maybe bleep his last name dan i'm not
trying to like
call anyone out
let me know when you're ready are you
still rolling okay
what sports did ethan play in high
school
well you were on the water polo team
that's true because i used to drive you
there every morning huh
yeah those were tough times
that was really early in the morning
yeah
you look so cute in your speedo though
stop
all the girls used to go eat this that's
something my mom always says oh my god
are you kidding all the girls were all
about the delusional thing like i
remember once with my mom we're walking
around
town and two girls i know from school
walk by and they just say hi to me
literally just hi oh no and i said hi
back and my mom spent the whole day
being like those girls are so into you
they're so in love with you you were so
cute how about who is that who's the guy
that did that caricature of you with all
the girls around oh stop it he was just
a high school caricature guy he was just
being nice oh ethan all the girls were
crazy about you okay
they were you were you were so charming
well thank you you were you were chasing
it sounds like you're unfortunately the
truth is not quite as she uh it is he's
he's totally playing it down he was he
was listening
well what you were saying was true i'd
love for that
okay ready what was this one i'm
interested if you're gonna get right
okay
what did i major in in college
creative writing yes
see okay all right
oh here's a this one's okay
has ethan ever smoked crack
i i don't think so wrong
really i tried crack one time
oh my god yeah
what happened
actually i i hit it lightly i was
hanging out with some friends and they
were they're like hey we got this cool
idea to just
take some coke and apparently they know
you oh my dad's nodding you know how to
make crack that
uh not personally but i've seen it done
yeah so they apparently you take a pen
i'm not gonna tell people how to do it
yeah don't don't but they made it and i
was like okay i'll give it a shot i hit
it once i didn't really feel it and that
was my crack experience i don't think we
ever smoked anything like that did we
speak for yourself dad did you try crack
before
i have once wow
what was your experience on crack ah
i was not unaffected by it okay okay
well tell me more about it how was the
experience was it positive where was i
uh yeah i mean you just get really high
and you can't do anything other than
just sit there really stoned but oh i
see it was
way back way back in the day it wasn't
just like a few months ago
oh god that smoking crack at um
while we were separated and oh damn dad
was down bad you guys separated he's out
there smoking crack
holy [ __ ] now you know why i said get
the hell
i can't i can't believe you you were
doing that
oh we're learning all kinds of stuff so
mom well mom you've never smoked crack
no
sorry
i well
your mother's done some pretty stupid
things i've tried we have drug related
questions coming up right oh god
so tell me what's the well tell me about
your drug experience what's the hardest
drugs you've done girl like in your
life
go ahead the hardest drug yeah
well
uh
probably dad you want to smoke crack
together
i just realized we should smoke crack
together
so you've done acid that's pretty hard
yeah that was pretty hardcore
and i did
well we i smoked crack so
yeah
you know but
i don't know did you do a lot of cocaine
and there was a period when you did a
lot of cooking i don't think i did a lot
of anything
i just kind of you know
explored
my options yeah when i was young but you
know
dad thinks it's made him a better person
i don't know made you a better person
i know like like
the hallucinogenic
you had like a uh
you had a kind of a grateful dead uh
acid awakening
only in his head definitely changes your
perspective on things on the world and
there is an interesting documentary on
netflix i think where they interviewed
lots of different people actors oh yeah
that's right about their experiences and
the commonality was just remarkable we
were watching something on tv about
carrie grant and carrie grant's one of
his wives got a boomer reference i don't
know who that is
you don't know who carrie grant is oh my
god he's like one of the most handsome
actors that ever lived let me pull up
the best hitchcock movies
oh yeah this is boomer's corner
oh my god that's horrible you don't know
who cary grant is wait
carrie by northwest
bruh i have literally never seen this
guy in my life oh my gosh this is a
boomer moment left gin too just like you
okay what is that what is that supposed
to mean a lot of people have cleft chins
well i'm just saying this guy he looks
like this guy is so handsome this is
like the husband who like beats his wife
because she didn't the coffee's not hot
enough
no way but he looks like oh no
carrie grant was like so cary grant
she's doing acid yeah his wife
introduced him
uh he
he had an uh i guess a difficult
childhood and had issues and so they
used it for therapy in in his shrinks
office and well i tried i've tried asked
a few times and they were every time
horrible yeah
i didn't like it either horrible every
time just worst time i like try it again
nope worst time ever no
no
pretty much no
i find that interesting that because i
know you guys like to smoke
well i don't really smoke marijuana any
more daddy but i hate it
you know maybe you do have a fat [ __ ]
and i have a tiny one
there are things different about us
apparently
no
you know what i don't like the feeling
of not being
you know in control in control yeah me
too and and when i turn when i get
really high i just turn into this
idiot i feel the same way yeah and i
just can't you know well you told me a
story once when you guys were tripping
acid and then dad you did it at your
house and the dad bailed and left you
there by yourself in your room and you
started like tripping balls oh my god no
no no
parents came home story no no no well
that's that's another part of the story
but at the very end of the day when dad
had to go home he was graduating from
ucla the next day and my brother was
getting married
and
i was i was in the bedroom and i was
still waiting when did you guys drop the
acid
you mean like what time of day yeah
where were you what were you doing oh my
god we had a bunch of people over mom's
parents had gone out of town supposedly
or gone somewhere they know they were
just out back they were just out and
uncle steven was getting married your
father was graduating from college i was
graduating
so you celebrate it by taking acid
because that was dad's idea
this is this is one of those things
where you you take it and then you go i
don't think i
yeah oh you took more oh
i was literally in the bathroom taking
off all of my clothes and my mother came
home or i don't know they just felt
uncomfortable okay okay
and because they cut it with i think
baby
no it was window pane and you can't
really see it this little clear plastic
and you would put it in your eye you put
plastic in your eyes no it was in your
it wasn't in my eye was in my mouth oh
why not just put it in your mouth why
put it in your eye that's how you did it
no i put mine in my mouth
i remember okay
okay well regardless of how you took it
after 20 minutes mom says i don't think
i'm coming on it's not working took
another half and inevitably you start to
come on to the first half as soon as you
take that second half oh no so i ran
into the bathroom and your father comes
after me and i'm taking off my clothes
and he's trying to put my clothes back
on and my mother comes home unexpectedly
oh my god running on the door what are
you doing in there and then my
grandfather my father's father whoa
who's there and he doesn't speak english
he's he speaks yiddish oh wow so he's
talking to yiddish and he's telling me
jokes and i'm laughing and he thought he
was the funniest guy wow he's like oh my
god she gets my humor and i'm i'm that
was like so did you even understand what
he was saying
some of it oh wow
some of it it was you know so he's just
not even speaking you guys aren't even
speaking the same language yeah yeah i'm
laughing i'm laughing and it was crazy
and the next day when dad was
was so i stayed up all night cleaning my
room okay so you guys dropped it at your
house and then eventually nighttime came
and dad had to bail
yeah and you were left in your room
still tripping balls so i just cleaned
it all night long wow how unlike you
and then you told me a story about that
happened recently or maybe not recently
but you were on the freeway and you had
like a flashback oh i did i did it was a
stage coach was coming i can't believe
you remembered that story so i mean it's
very i was on the freeway driving home
from work and all of a sudden there was
a stage coach
with horses on the freeway on the
freeway heading toward me it must have
been for a second it seemed more like a
couple of minutes but it must have been
it was coming towards you yeah
very strange la maybe it really was a
statement that's what i was going to
want i was saying is it possible there
was a stage coast and horses on this a
good reason not to do this
this story but it you know whatever and
how was the rest of your night dad
uh
who knows i don't remember i think the
only thing i remember is mom locked
herself in the bathroom
then her parents came home and i'm also
tripping my brains out but i have to
maintain like everything's cool and talk
to her parents and they never got on to
what was going on nope all these well we
don't think so
your parents would have no your dad
would have freaked out yeah yeah maybe
maybe yeah
wow you guys what a bad influence you
were okay well mike the question was did
ethan ever smoke crack you answered that
incorrectly i did
i'm shocked
oh shocking sounds like you guys been up
to way crazier [ __ ] than me
so what is something not a lot of people
know about me
wow
a lot wow something they don't know
about you
um
i think your fans know how what a great
person you are
thank you but that was not the question
what did people
not know about you
um
god do you want to talk about what a
great person i am
well you are a great person you're so
sweet that's to be fair that's kind of a
hard question i don't know what i would
say
what's something that i know about me
you don't ride a motorcycle
so why would people not know that about
me no they wouldn't because you don't
you don't ride a motorcycle
i haven't been to the moon you haven't
been to the men that's true
right i what do they not know about it
do you want to take a pass on this one
um that you do a lot of cooking
okay there you go that's pretty good i
mean eli doesn't really cook ethan is
the chef in the house yes that's true
that's why i thought you liked pasta
because you're always cooking pasta yeah
it's not like you didn't know me my
whole entire life growing up that's for
teddy all right well all right let's
skip this one it's a hard one have i
ever [ __ ] myself as an adult
maybe i don't know
yes or no mom okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
go on a limb and say
yes
well you were there it was in las vegas
oh that's right you told me that story
yeah
why why did you what happened i think i
just had food poisoning or something i
was feeling good
and i just you know dad got food
poisoning at what was the name of that
place the tomato place don't mention it
don't mention the name wait you shoot
your pants wait call them out no no no
what it was the two tame hot tamales
it was these two people women that
opened it it was at mandalay bay
mandible bay you shade your pants
restaurant oh my god he got so sick he
let me drive home that's how sick he was
your dad was really he got food
poisoning
it was just a throw up sit down diarrhea
stand up throw up sit down diarrhea
so you didn't chew your pants you didn't
even soil your underwear no i managed to
get there no sharding i'm afraid not
would have been a better story but no
have you ever seen your pants as an
adult
i have not
that's [ __ ]
okay let's move on actually i realize my
dad doesn't have a camera so people are
just staring at me but at least he's got
a mic
okay here we're moving on to the next
part okay okay you know what i just
thought would be a fun idea maybe next
week dad can come in the hot seat and we
can switch it up every week that sounds
familiar i don't know if i'm prepared
for that yeah yes you'll be great uh
okay here we go ready ready
when i was young when i was a teenager
or younger any point in my life what was
the thing i did that upset you the most
oh
man you used to oh my god
you were a stinker is there one incident
that stands out where i [ __ ] up like
the hardest
um
one particular thing
no you weren't awful
you weren't awful i remember
specifically oh i know something that i
found out later
i don't know if i'd say it pissed me off
but
i used to have a stash of money
in my closet yeah i had a lot of cash
because i was a hair stylist so i got
you know a lot of cash tips
and i used to tell the kids
this is where the money is if you ever
need money
it's it's there
and years later i found out that you
were taking money out that's what you
said you said here's money if you need
it take the money i know what was i
supposed to do but the thing is is that
you didn't tell me and so i thought the
maid was no no that was different
i would take like a 20 out every once in
a while right but what this is a
different incident because
my mom she used to have like thousands
of dollars of cha of bills and just out
they're basically out in the open
no it wasn't i was not thinking i was
not taking that much money from you that
was not me oh okay all right well then
now i don't feel so bad yeah
i wasn't committed i let the maid go
because i thought oh my god i think she
probably was stealing from you that
wasn't me okay okay i would take like a
20 out so why didn't you just tell me
well
because
it felt wrong i felt like i was doing
something wrong i know you should have
just told me and i would have just given
you money oh stop you don't just give me
money yes i do
i would give you money yeah okay yeah
i'm sorry why do you think i told you
guys that you i was a kid by the way oh
you know oh i know what you did well my
mom goes she and then once she fired the
maid for stealing because she had like
literally gobs of cash
just sitting out in the open it wasn't
out in the open it was it was behind a
bag
no it was hanging it was literally my
clothes one
closet
like this where she did her accounting
and stuff and then it was like right
there in an envelope
it was in an envelope but it was in a
bag in hanging in well whatever well
anyway it doesn't surprise me that she
was taking money yeah yeah i had to let
her
go uh this on nascimiento yeah
no that happened on havasu when the st
and then when we moved to a new house
you got a safe built and you told us all
the code so you know listen
i'm a broke ass kid
well it didn't cost us thousands of
dollars but it might have when you were
gary how old was ethan when he started
making those phone calls to playboy
[Laughter]
yes
oh man ethan no he was younger than that
he was way younger than that he called
up gary had playboy this is when when
men had playboy magazine
and you stole one of dad's playboys and
you would call the number and there was
a woman's voice that that answered and
the minute you heard the woman's voice
you hung up so we had like a hundred
phone calls and they charged us
all this money and dad called and said
you know
he told them what happened i have a
young son and and then they waved the
charge amazing they waived the charges
yeah well that yeah it was like eight
hundred dollars was it right really it
was so much money 20 calls
i don't know what was going on in my
little kid head but i would see this
number
and then i would go hide and call it and
then yeah the minute i would hear
someone's voice i would get scared and
hang up yeah i don't know how you
possibly could got charged eight hundred
dollars for that
but i did call a lot of times
that was one of those uh you know you
have to pay to call type yeah but it's
like things there i have so many stories
about you
that is just a crack up but i i don't
think that it made me mad
should i tell this i remember you
slapped me one time oh
i did i slapped your sister i called you
the b word
oh you used to get so mad at me used to
say
i hate you stupid and i used to say
that's too bad because i love you
and then you'd get really bad that's not
when you slapped me
but i deserved it but i think i pissed
her off one time she actually slapped me
yeah i slapped your sister once and i
think when you slapped me i was like i
deserved that and i just walked off yeah
and we didn't talk about it anymore
maybe maybe i said your mom you're being
such a b word and then you were like you
didn't say that [ __ ] to me yeah crossed
the line that's that's
can't cross that line
yeah but
you did all kinds of crazy things
yeah well that's what happened when your
parents are never home oh just saying
we're right here we're working yeah hey
listen you guys are at work the only
thing is your home listen you guys work
and you know i and for a kid who raised
him raised himself then uh god bless and
thanks for the 20s listen wait wait wait
till you have your third child and then
they start raising themselves and then
you'll understand
maybe you're right
oh my god okay here's the next one
making me feel guilty now
in the beginning of my youtube career
yeah did you take what i was doing
seriously be honest
when you were living in israel when i
was living in israel and i quit my job
to do youtube full-time i did oh stop it
that's a lie that's such a lie i thought
i'd be honest i thought what you were
doing was kind of crazy and i thought
when you quit your job that
maybe you should think about it because
you know when we moved here
i wanted you to go back you literally
were like
i moved we moved from israel
to back to the states and we briefly
lived with my parents in las vegas in
the interim while we were figuring our
stuff out and my mom was riding my ass
every day to quit doing youtube and
because i never said to quit i said it's
always good to have something to fall
back on you want me to go to school to
get a t uh education degree and then
become a teacher
well i just i was already making good
money at that time like more than i
would make as a teacher
i don't i don't know i just always think
it's always a good idea to have a fall
back but
you know dad's shaking yourself no i
always tell me the truth no i was you
better get a real job ethan get a real
job because in the early days everything
was duty jokes and well some things
never changed oh you didn't believe it
there's a lot of that you know at the at
the beginning like most youtubers it's
all family and friends and 100
subscribers and
you know to see where you've gotten from
there it's pretty you've definitely
evolved i'm not telling you to get a
real job anymore yeah
but there so
you know it's funny one of my closest
friends who i won't name
this is how down bad it was for me i
used to send in my videos early in the
day in the days of my
career not really career but exploration
and he was like dude he's like dude you
got to stop sending me your videos
[Laughter]
he's like listen i just don't have time
for this [ __ ]
but you know oh god i always i always
used to say to you kids
that you should do what you love and do
what you're good at and don't chase the
money the money will become follow you
in the int
i was like mom but i was like mom i'm
making like 10 000 a month
you're like go become a teacher it's
like i'm making good money
i don't remember that
i don't remember that
were you ever were you ever embarrassed
by any of the videos i made i know some
of the first ones yeah oh my god oh my
god there was one video where you were
you had your your pants down low and you
were shaking
i'm like oh my god ela's father's gonna
have a heart attack yeah the shake the
dick video oh my god
that's not my son i have no idea who
that is well for those who don't know
the story you know at the time shake
that ass by sean paul was it
shake that thing
and i was like listen
what's why the girls all shaking their
ass why the guys don't get to
participate in this so i say shake that
dick
well you did you suck
you shook all night live the problem
with that video is that um
well everything frankly
ela's dad disowned me pretty much oh my
god this thing keeps on whacking me in
the face
okay it's not moving you're whacking all
right all right
cause it's so big
oh gary
any other videos just to shake that dick
um
well
that one really screams out at me yeah
that one
i got you
i stand by that video honestly
i think it is funny i think the concept
was good well but it was uh you know as
your mother it was a little shocking
um do you remember a time when i got the
most trouble growing up oh yeah you got
in a lot of trouble
i remember
you your brother and your sister all had
the same biology teacher
they used to refer to
all three of them as the kleinsteins
because they always got really good
grades and were very smart
and um
i went to pick up ethan from school this
was the last day of school and i
that must have been your last period of
the day and what was his name wilson
was that the biology team his name mr
wilson
and he says oh you're ethan's mom i go
yeah he goes he's the best part-time
student i ever had
i go part-time what do you mean what is
he getting in your class he goes oh he
got an a i go well why do you say
part-time he goes because he ditches all
the time
and instead of getting you know like way
to go you got an a i man i was so pissed
off that you like
you're you're skipping class well i
think that was when i was 18 because i
because you
held me back a grade let's not forget so
this is your fault i didn't know when i
was who holds a kid back in elementary
school my teacher was like your kid is
too [ __ ] dumb too advanced no to the
next grade and from from kindergarten
bro who gets held back from kindergarten
i had to go to i had to go to
grade one and a half ethan you were
always smart why did i go to grade one
and a half because they said you were
immature immature i'm [ __ ] i'm a
child what's not what's the they held me
back your age don't act like a kid i
don't know listen i did wanted you to
told him to shove it
stand up for your child well i thought i
thought maybe you would do you put me on
the short bus better i don't know they
listen they said you were immature dad
did you not have a conversation with
this how was it how does a kindergarten
teacher decide to hold back a child for
being immigrant they did that with sean
too and sean was a smartie pants just
like you who are these people i think
they were changing the tracks though
from like when i went to school back in
the 1800s they had like an a and a b so
depending upon your birthday you either
graduated yeah but ethan's in january in
june they so they i think it was a well
we can push them ahead with the older
kids or let them you know stay back and
be like you'll be the king among the
small people or the small people person
among your kings and it's always better
to i don't know but be the big dog i it
was not mike
i remember the only person from my class
that came with me was literally the
dumbest person i had known and that
holds true to was it kyle no don't put
this on there mom
yes
[Laughter]
but kyle's not dumb kyle's smiling no it
wasn't kyle and kyle you're thinking it
was a different kyle oh good oh yeah oh
i know who you're talking about the one
that had the the little girl that was
why are you giving details okay okay the
people i grew up with okay okay okay
okay well i say where he lives you want
to say his last name sorry
the dumbest person i ever lived no okay
i have another ethan story
when you were young it's a good story
well kind of
uh you know sometimes you would get into
trouble
and i got a phone call from the office
saying i needed to come in
and i thought uh oh what did ethan do
so i showed up at the office
and they had some kind of a
an art contest with all the different
schools in in the in the uh districts
like ventura opposed to la and yada yada
anyway so um
they were art projects and so i'm
waiting in the in the office you know to
talk to the principal
and there were these all the i was
looking at all the the pictures on the
wall and there was this one picture that
just i was drawn to it was a really
great picture
and i
they were these were all done by
students and there was this one really
great picture and it was a picture of a
little boy
and you could see it was the back of him
it wasn't the front of him and he was
looking out like over the world
it was a really awesome picture and i
looked i i thought to myself god what
what kid drew this this is amazing and
it was you
it was you
it said ethan klein and the reason why
happen yes
dad it doesn't don't remember it but it
didn't ah no i was hanging in the louvre
now no it was you and i remember save
that painting okay let me explain
no no no let me explain so i the reason
why i was called into the office is
because they needed my permission to
to enter this
this picture
and so i said okay but i want it back
and they said oh yeah we'll get it back
and they never gave it back yeah well i
remember all those all the art i made in
high school that i really liked that you
threw out so i'm pretty sure wherever
that painting is and now it's in the
same place it would have been if you got
it back no
no no where's the heart where's the art
there was one picture where's the art i
she threw it out she has no sentiment at
all no where's the heart i don't know i
there was a lot of things that got lost
when we were in coming back from mexico
you don't lose things you care about all
the pictures of me as a child i don't
have one picture of myself as a child
very clearly you don't care that much
about that either no they lost it dust
catchers this is one of the boxes they
lost it
i had all these those were gone
okay whatever i'm not that mad about i
just think it's
no where's the art
i'll be then
have you oh my god this is vulgar oh
your friends are gonna think i'm a
horrible person now no they won't they
won't think that have you this okay i'm
just gonna say this it's hard for me to
say this but i'm just going to say it
have you ever caught me jerking off
no
but i have a funny story that you've
never heard do you want me to share it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this is why
we're
here i can't believe i'm gonna do you
know the story are you no he no i never
told anybody
this is something that i have never i
i've never shared this with okay let's
hear it i'm nervous it's time to
introduce it okay are you serious you
want me to tell this well i have a story
that i'm going to tell about you that
i've never told anyone
oh god
oh my god totally fair
really go ahead all right all right i'll
tell it oh my god i can't believe i'm
sharing this story we lived on nasa
miento
yes
and you know that green couch that you
absolutely loved
yes
you had fallen asleep yeah and you know
you always used to walk around in your
boxers okay
and you fell asleep yeah and you know
how sometimes in the morning when you
yeah
well something popped through this slit
in your boxers and
i turned around and there you were
sleeping and i was like horrified so i
took a blanket and i threw it out for
you
that's not that bad
i was expecting something worse oh no it
is embarrassing though that's
embarrassing for you i never i can't
believe you had me telling that story
well wait till you hear yours oh my god
is it really yeah don't tell it then
too late
don't i don't know i mean listen it's
just it's not that bad it's just people
being people kind of thing
tell it to death and then and then no no
i'm gonna die oh god no ethan okay so so
you've never sexual oh i have a story um
one tell me if you remember this
one time
this this was i must have been like wow
i don't even know definitely under 10.
i was
this was when me and sean my brother
sean were sharing a room we had a bunk
bed okay yeah i remember that and it
must have been one of the first times i
ever
masturbated yeah
and i passed out
wow good job
thank uh no don't accept that compliment
anyway
i
passed out and i woke up with my
pants down below my knees
on the bed and then you were in the room
like cleaning or something and not
acknowledging it i have no memory of
that at all okay because i i have just
no memory of that you were just
cleaning as if i wasn't there maybe i
didn't know maybe i didn't know you were
there maybe they're the same stories no
no no no no definitely not the same
stuff no i have no
i have no memory of that at all
no i can't believe you just shared that
oh just wait it's worse oh my god well i
was just because i have that memory i
was just wondering if you you're always
walking around in your boxers sean broad
remember remember sean's old girlfriend
lily yeah she was so embarrassed you
walked in the room and you had your
boxers on and she was like oh my god
i said ethan put your pants on i was
just normal i mean i wasn't naked i was
just wearing i know but she was like
really well she was a girl and she was
the only child and so she was like
horrified okay
i mean we grew up just me and sean in
the house so it was normal i didn't
think anything of it that's just what
you wear at home at home i know well
it's funny because at the very beginning
of our of dad's and my marriage it was
like a household of women because
jessica yeah you have a sister too yeah
well yeah so it was like like a ten
years dad stop wearing your underwear
around the house jessica's getting older
and then she left and then you then it
turned into a house for just all boys so
then i was the odd man pretty
interesting out
so um that's pretty amazing that i was
able to grow up without ever being
caught jerking off though no i don't
ever remember
is that norm have you ever been caught
jerking off you guys just casually like
i feel like that's inevitable but it's
kind of amazing that i was able to
navigate my adolescence without taking
that l
yeah thank you
[Applause]
you did one thing that i don't know if
ela would appreciate me telling this
what did i do
we were we were we were you really want
me to tell it yeah i don't know what it
could possibly be that would piss elof
well it i don't know that it would piss
her off it's just kind of
embarrassing you were you were at the
dating age and we were at nacimiento and
there was a girl this was remember you
were in that german class
and there was a girl that you took
upstairs and
she you sh oh
ethan we thought what's ethan doing up
there you had the door closed
i'm telling you ethan you were a ladies
man
[Laughter]
move on
i got
all the girls the parent the doc the
mothers were in love with you too
i was good with moms oh my god all the
moms were in love with you did you know
that i used to smoke weed in my room
uh i don't think so dad caught me once
you did you walked in and you go
you're like oh
just do that outside you look kind of
guilty outside even though i'm sure you
smoke inside but you're like oh
oh just do it in the backyard as if you
want me taking bond grips in the
backyard i think you just panicked
at least when i
was doing that and live with my folks
i'd go into the bathroom and take a pipe
and stand up on top of the toilet there
was listen i had the door closed i had a
towel there i was blowing it out the
window you just you know you barked in
yeah you just barged into my room
you do one knock
and then immediately open police
one knock open that's barging
gary police barging yeah i apologize
yeah well listen it's your house but you
would you say if you're going to pour
half you're gonna if you're gonna barge
into your kid's room you better be
prepared
for what you may see
you know could have been worse
yes
yeah
i don't remember you ever smoking in the
house
yeah i just remember dad all flustered
like i should do i should say something
but i don't know what to say
take that in the back where's mine give
me that let me let me take that okay
here's the story okay
oh ethan
i don't know
how bad is it
am i gonna be totally embarrassed
let's find out
oh i don't know if i can handle this
okay one time oh
brother
well you know when you're a kid
and you're home alone and you start
rummaging through your parents stuff
like that's pretty normal right you just
had to curiosity i know where this is
going
oh my god
i know what you're gonna say no don't
say it
and please don't say that's your
father's fault you're the one that
bought that stuff and so i found in my
mom's side
oh god please do not say it please don't
say it i'm gonna be well it's gonna
sound worse it's gonna sound worse than
it is now you don't even know what it is
i know exactly what it is
it was i don't know if i was young
or
because i was small so things seemed
bigger maybe oh it was no it was huge it
was the biggest [ __ ] dildo i have
ever seen in my life father is
for exhibition purposes only
your father and i was just it's a it's a
it's just a
it's like a
moment that i'll that was forever burned
in my brain it was like
god why are you doing in my my drawer i
just said i don't know you're a kid you
just you're curious what you just looked
at your parents [ __ ] oh my god i was
really young i'm so embarrassed it was
[ __ ] the sun
i mean the way i remember it was like
the size of my whole arm it was huge
your father like oh jesus christ like
he's perverted your dad he's the one
that he's the culprit that buys that
stuff don't look at me dad
my dad's staring at me and i can't look
at him right now it was life-size
no oh my god
if you're an elephant
so yeah i found that
oh my god who's gonna be watching this
all these people are gonna be watching
well you gotta know your kid's gonna
find that you gotta lock that up in a
better place
if you have like a
you know 10 year old child they're gonna
find everything in the house
well she thought the cash would distract
you i think leaving piles of cash all
over found that too
oh my god
his idea was this anyway shawn saw it
too by the way
oh
my god
did you really yeah oh my god oh cause i
was like dude shawn you got to see this
oh lord gary that's the thing that's
what you do
you know my older brother worked only
two and a half years apart so everything
we were like you gotta see this [ __ ] oh
my god
we may have shown it to some friends too
oh
no
oh lord
oh my god i can't even imagine
hey yeah just the realization your
parents have sex is unnerving enough but
dude this is another level oh that's
horrifying
dude you had like a 20 inch [ __ ]
elephant [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh god i'm so embarrassed
how much was that thing i don't know ask
your father he's the one that bought
these crazy ass toys
okay well i'm glad we're on the same
page there
all right um our next segment mom
is you got to translate
some uh sayings that the kids are saying
you know like back when i was young
people started saying cool oh right or
something i think okay yeah
let's do a test one what does sick mean
sick means it's it's good yes okay
so here i'm gonna no i couldn't
understand it when everyone was saying
sick i'm going why is everyone sick
okay go ahead so i'm gonna give you some
examples okay and you tell me what you
think it means
paparazzi team bryce on god
what
paparazzi team bryce on god
well paparazzi are are people that take
photographs right
on team bryce
so that's about someone by the name of
bryce good
on god paparazzi team bryce on god
not on guard but on god on god on god
i have no idea it means we support um
it means everybody supports bryce
oh even the even the paparazzi are team
bryce on god oh team bryce bryce oh uh
well bret the name doesn't matter it's
just team paparazzi or team gary on god
okay well
okay i didn't i didn't no problem no
problem
okay this one is called no cap no cap
no there's so there's no cap on
something no cap
right so
off the off the ceiling or out of this
world or
or
well i think what it means is
so here i'll give you a usage no cap
this is the best food i've had
so that's that's a good thing because if
you put a cap on something you can't you
know if there's no cap then it's
infinite it's it's it's good so okay no
cap okay i figured that one out well no
no cap means i'm not kidding
all right
right
no
he means no yeah no no lie well all
right so i'm being serious right now no
cap no cap all right
do you know what lit means for example
you would say
you know on fire
yeah lit
and yeah so you would say when you light
them you say it was a lit it was on fire
six mango white claws at the saddle
ranch last night it was lit
it was good it was good
congrats you nailed that one okay
well that one was easy okay how about
this one bruh moment
bruh moment
well a lot of people i've noticed your
generation say the word bra
moment finding my parents sex toys is a
major bra moment
well then it's an awareness
yes
an awareness
like uh a surprising i think you would
call it a uh
yeah surprising uh a an impactful moment
maybe a moment of of a
surprise do we like that definition
shock yeah disbelief a bra moment where
you just say to yourself bruh
like oh my god would you say bruh
i wouldn't but apparently
bruh just say for me bruh bruh yeah
bruh
how's it bro
no that wouldn't work
we're talking about bruh bruh
not to be confused with bra
i can't i can't tell the difference
okay here's a one ma'am this is a
wendy's
ma'am this is a wendy's
as in it's not a taco bell it's a
wendy's i'll give you an example after
some oh wait is this the answer
or is it
am i supposed to read this
ma'am this is a wendy's
yeah ma'am this is a wendy's
so this is for when someone tell tells
you something you don't care about
and you say this ma'am this is a wendy's
so it's not important no it says if you
were telling it to a wendy's
drive-through
operator that's so much like oh
i thought i said wendy's opposed to taco
bell so i kind of got the win you did so
long-winded rant
someone would respond ma'am this is a
wendy's
okay exactly not important it's
irrelevant how about this
this hits different
it's different
this hit's different it's different so
this pineapple and all of pizza hits
different
so it's unusual it's good
exactly it's unusual and it's good okay
well done yeah thank you
rent free
rent free
this person is living in your mind rent
free
um
[Music]
well obviously you think about the
person
without them doing something maybe maybe
they're in love with you mm-hmm
obsessed with you yes rent free yeah
you're obsessed with this person because
they're in your head yes you'll be
living in their head rent free boy you
guys got a lot of weird sayings
oh yeah okay this one chugi
chugi chugi
it's not like a candy bar
here i have an example i have a video
example for you who writes these things
up
the kids man
wow this one here's an example of chugi
i have recently remembered the word
chuhi means so i'm going to make a list
of things that i think are chewy just a
psa if you like any of these things
that's okay we can have different
opinions number one chug is the gucci
belt
this should have been left in 2016 um
unless you are like a 50 year old mom
going to a business meeting i have such
a burning hatred for fong flip-flops my
friends asked me for permission to wear
them in front of me
this kind of denim like really ripped
and skinny it lived it a great time i
loved them so much but i think it's time
to put them down
unfortunately the louie never full is
like very chewy to me and it's also most
of louis vuitton i feel like is like
kind of chewed a little bit of course
literally anything right do they mean
like
um passe
definitely i think that's a great
definition for chugi a little out of a
little
out of date is that right do we like
that
little passe
thank you okay this one this one your
this is a good one that was hard though
i couldn't understand what she was
saying the glizzy oh that's a weird one
the glizzy i could really go for a lizzy
chewy chew
i'll have to remember that
this is so cheeky my girlfriend's gonna
go what the hell what language you're
speaking okay what is that what is the
new word i could really go for a glizzy
down my throat right now a glizzy
i wanna gobble a glizzy
glizzy
gobble a glizzy glitch okay put it in
context
i could really go for a glizzy right now
that really doesn't help
i like my glizzy with mustard and
ketchup
glizzy a hot dog it is a hot dog
wow
well i mean i don't know how she's gonna
get that galizzi
very good a glizzy's a hot dog where do
they come up with the word glizzy for
hot dogs i love is that a brand or
something the glizzy brand yes
it is no it's not
simp
simple you can't stop watching hot tub
streams you simp
you're such a simp for her
simp
sap sim no i'm saying simp no but i'm
saying does it mean is it
that's a little too vague
gonna need a more specific answer on
simp
you're too you give in too easily you're
too easily persuaded
i mean that's what sap would be when
you're not bad that's one of our words
we're halfway there
simp short for simpleton
right is someone who
uh let's say blindly uh
uh
worship someone do we like worship
someone who worships somebody
a simple
like you would yeah devotion like you
would say these people who watch like
these streamer girls and donate all
their money and don't miss a stream are
simps
simps
or idiots
sure yeah
some people might say that
here's another one
vibe check
vibe check
vibe check
checking out the atmosphere in the room
like getting your
you know you're
[Music]
checking out the vibe how is the
situation you would do a video
temperature in the room so steven
crowder [ __ ] himself he did not pass the
vibe check
cool it's something that's not cool
i think you're right when you when you
check the vibe you're you're when you
pass the vibe check you're good to hang
yeah you can hang yeah steven crowder
[ __ ] his pants he cannot hang
do we like that and we accept that okay
oh this is good i'm doing okay
t
where's the t right here is t right
good you got it i know is that it yeah
that's it it's just t no what does it
mean
what does t mean t
there's so much t to keep up with lately
news
not exactly
uh
t
there's a lot of tea with ethan lately i
can't keep up with it all
no you can't answer you're not
you're not answering yeah you look like
you were gonna answer he does that well
dad knows the tea because he's been
following it
dude my dad was watching all the t
channels
oh
you know you want to give an answer
daddy no wait let me guess let me get t
uh just the the happenings the the uh
the current events
not specific enough dad go ahead drama
drama
coming out with that 2000
drama two thousand points so t is drama
yes where's the t
oh
all over youtube
what is the origin of t i know there's
the kermit meme is it really the kermit
meme no
what is team why where does tea come
yeah we're i mean china i believe
originally
what that's a dad joke
like you think the chinese are the only
people that drink tea dad i mean what
are you implying
you ask where it came from
india
in china
black drag culture that's interesting
very influential group
yeah
um beef we haven't talked about the beef
what does beef mean if you have beef
something's beefy someone that's big and
no if you have beef with another person
what does that mean oh you have a beef
with them you have an a disagreement
right a conflict right very good
okay you did pretty good there
thank you what does on god mean i know
we talked about paparazzi on god what
does on god mean
uh in good graces maybe in good graces
we go
on god did i get it right it means i'm
telling the truth oh right all right
well on god
you have the altar yeah we accept that
okay not what you say before a sword
fight
oh no that's ours
there you go oh there's another joke
right so we've got we're moving on to
our final segment here how much time do
we have dan
uh
you got plenty of time okay
okay here we are with our next segment
okay this one's called who's the boomer
now but behind me you will see
an enormous puzzle
which looks like a for me to solve
start here and here
okay
before my mom she has the task
a simple task as simple of connecting
your phone to that bluetooth speaker oh
my god i'll never be able to do that
it's a simple feat i mean
it's but most everybody can do it it's
just connect i mean connect with
bluetooth what do i have to do well hold
on we're not starting yet
oh [ __ ] you're gonna connect your phone
your smartphone uh-huh to that bluetooth
speaker
yeah
this uh bose bluetooth speaker
you are gonna connect to your phone
to this speaker to this bluetooth
speaker and i think i think the the uh
the finish line should just be playing
some something out of it or whatever
yeah it could be a video or
whatever look at the size of this puzzle
i mean no way i'll be here forever
it's a simple matter people do it every
day it's a bluetooth speaker it's a
modern-day smartphone hold on don't get
you're already started
wait put that thing away
i don't know how to do it i don't have a
clue yeah how long you've been using
smartphones now
for well a long time for a while i think
it's about time that you should be able
to connect something bluetooth to your
phone
well regardless here put your phone up
top all right um
okay are we ready to do that
gary you know what let's have a you can
have a life line in like let's say two
minutes or three minutes my dad can come
try to help oh okay gary do you know how
to do it but
only he can only give you verbal
explanations he cannot touch your phone
okay
and i'll take it even further he can't
point to anything he can only use his
words to describe gary do you know how
to do it
maybe
dad's work he's not so confident either
all right
all right so in two minutes you can let
my dad go
okay
you think that that's too long how long
do you think this is gonna take maybe
one minute oh my god that's easier to do
than what i have to do
one minute that's totally easier to do
than we only have a minute to do it no
no no no in one minute you get dad to
come in and help you but dad listen yes
you cannot touch your phone
you can only use your words you cannot
point to anything
you can't touch it okay
all right ready i'll never be able to
put the timer down or well yeah we'll
start i have to i have to be able to
connect hold on this to this no this
phone to this speaker
the laptop don't worry about the laptop
that's for the next part right you know
when i'm in my car it just automatically
transfers
well let's see if that works here
okay okay ready you understand the
instructions this phone to this speaker
and then play a sound out of the speaker
that's all you have to do
okay
all right here we go ready lord two one
go okay here we go all right starting
the puzzle let's see connect with the y
airplane
let's see here i am going oh
what is if i screw something up with my
phone
i don't know
how that should have been here let me
that shouldn't really be possible i
don't think you're going to screw up
your phone trying to connect the
bluetooth okay
hurry i don't know how to do it
link win links to it okay so
describe what you're working on
currently mom well i opened up settings
and i went into connections with wi-fi
and then i saw something that said
wait where'd it go mobile hot spot and
tethering
oh turn that off okay
you you
okay just just just describe everything
you're okay you're doing uh mobile
networks
more connection settings wait this thing
is more connection settings on the board
what the hell is this i got a nearby
device is scanning on
you're not supposed to put points okay
go back okay
no pointing dad okay only words so go
back to your main screen okay so i've
got i've got this one
or pull the mic okay i've got i've got
connections wi-fi bluetooth connection
so i'm going to turn that on
and then it says here
uh
more connection settings
that's what i would look for that's what
i pushed it says nearby device scanning
okay keep going uh well it doesn't
that's it that's all it does go back to
settings
go back to settings
do you know which one is your bluetooth
sign yes this one okay turn that off
okay now turn it back on oh okay
bluetooth again like crazy make sure you
pull up scroll up okay so now you're
looking for this
device i don't even know what it is
hey i didn't touch it i saw you pointing
no pointing point pointing no pointing
at your words can i point with my nose
no no
oh wait there's something that says
living room stop the top one there
pose make sure the speaker is on oh we
got a hint make sure the speaker is on
how do i know if it's on hey hey hey hey
oh
oh that's cheating tell mom what to do
okay it's on now
she got to know how to turn a speaker on
how's that cheating is that a big
mystery to turn the speaker on wait a
second let's see what happens bluetooth
pairing requests okay
okay you guys monitoring him to make
sure he's not pointing allow access
allow
see i would have never been able to push
that unless you told me because i didn't
know that that was for speaker
play music
play music okay okay wait pinterest even
on youtube pinterest i like pinterest
pinterest a string dress she's going on
pinterest on pinterest you mean pandora
pandora i'm sorry i meant pandora
oh
no way
thank you wow dad thank you very much
dad spoiled it with all the pointing you
know what i got most of it except for
that one thing okay now wait a part two
bonus round dad sit back down mom you
have to now play sound out of your phone
you're off the bluetooth and back to the
phone go
okay
uh
let me see oh we can't play this music
it's copyrighted wait wait wait okay oh
here i'll just turn it down
it's my it's through giberto
don't tell them they'll claim they'll be
okay all right go ahead didn't eat me
okay
hi shrimp you can't hear the music can
you dan no okay
very well okay so now i have to be back
on my phone let me play music out of
your phone now
oh
no
no
wait a minute oh sure
wait a minute puzzle is endless look at
this thing i'm like
i'm getting here i don't oh wait wait i
almost remembered
wait i almost forgot here so take off
good good
so now okay well i went back to my
settings and i turned off my what my my
bluetooth okay so now i'm gonna go back
to the bluetooth because it's off
and and
[Music]
oh lord
[ __ ] okay wait let me see if i can do
this i think i'm getting close make a
sound come out of your phone i'm trying
what did you do before
you beat me i might stop the music
okay you good job yeah you did it
i'm impressed
boomer
this is a tough puzzle man i don't know
yeah you had no chance can i try i mean
yeah i think i felt i was getting close
you already won what do you want to try
my half done puzzle what do you want to
do with it
okay we have another challenge boomer
puzzle part two
i will be completing this massive sudoku
puzzle i think that's gonna be easier
i'm not good at sudoku and this looks
pretty hard to me i mean i've played it
like a long time ago so i'm not really
up to date with all the patterns and
stuff
and mom
will be she has a notepad here
and a laptop in front of her the
instructions for your puzzle are on the
notepad as when the timer starts you
will read the notepad so i'm going to be
using the computer yes to solve your
boomer puzzle not my phone
boomer puzzle is on the laptop okay so i
can get rid of this okay so um i'm ready
okay so on your mark ready mom right
yeah you're gonna flip over the paper
and read it into the microphone go okay
okay family's podcast okay do i need to
write family's podcast challenge at no
okay send email to
dan
and it has your address oh i think i
at h3h3productions.com
with attachment of file
donna meme what is that a jpeg
jpeg which is located on the desktop
oh stupid
send an email to dan okay
wait how do i get over here
and to be clear i created an email
account for you that's that email
address at the top and i gave you the
password as well the password is that
string of characters boomer puzzle is to
send an attachment on an email
i don't even know how to make a damn
email from here from
looking okay okay okay here we go
wait okay podcast h3 podcast release
could that be it oh is it here ian okay
so let's send you
yeah why dan there you are
oh right right sign okay so it'd be here
or here so you're not going to be
signing in to my email though it says
sign
signed out possibly
and email to dan
right with the attachment of the file
don right but you need to send it from
the families podcast email that i
created for you and i gave you the
password on that sheet of paper okay
wait what just happened
i i don't know you you've seemed to open
some sort of dictionary thing
dictionary podcast i opened up a
dictionary yeah i'm not sure what's
going on there okay wait how do i get
this off
probably just click anywhere to click
click off of it nothing's happening
so once again my mom is simply trying to
send an attachment on an email and i'm
doing the launch codes for nasa over
here why won't this go off you can see
everything she's doing dan yes this is
awesome wait
i can't get it all right wait let me see
if i can go back
i can't do this though oh okay there we
go
all right so
dan i can just push anything and it'll
it'll
why does this key oh gmail okay there we
go gmail
now you seem to have somehow activated
some strange uh dictionary mode
i'm not sure how you did that
don't help her dan
don't help her
dan said i can push anything in and it
should come up but i'm so confused why
is this not coming out
i don't trust him
oh
i well because then i can't see the the
damn computer nothing this is just okay
all right wait so how do i punch this
there's no like mouse or anything
oh uh
there's a track pad on it are you not
have you never used one of those before
apple thesaurus
why does this keep coming up
to be honest i don't know i i have no
idea what i have no idea where to click
okay here we go enter my password
so that must be
you
okay
[Music]
well no it's fine she can say the
password you can see the password
[Laughter]
show password let me see if i can see
what i'm looking at
is this case sensitive
it is yeah oh it is yeah the password's
case sensitive yeah
okay wait no result what the hell
oh laugh it up dan
wait a minute where's the x so i can
back oh is this a four
yes you don't even have an x on here to
bet okay delete i'm just going to delete
delete delete delete this is so hard
okay
control how do i make this
what oh [ __ ] my bad d
all right
dan that'd be a five beer no that's
impossible
one two
hey how come you're here helping ethan
you're helping nathan that's not fair
no it's true
oops damn
okay we're making good progress here how
are you doing on the email i have no
idea i don't know what the hell
what's going on over there
okay so next i'm not gonna say anything
next okay so you're trying to log into
the e enter the password i didn't do it
right
oh my god so you're just going to keep
i'm going to keep going oh wait a minute
maybe this is the password yeah what you
just typed it is what i
so this is a uh two
no
am i am i doing this wrong dan oh i see
is this a seven yeah you're on the right
track
okay
all right let's see if i got this right
two
l two okay so this is the one and this
oh stop
no okay
i'm on next what is this a one it's
something's happening
i signed in okay now what what
okay
if you like take a few minutes to help
google work better for you
what's wrong here i need a little help
add or confirm your recovery email or
phone number at home address what
i don't need any of that okay so what am
i supposed to do sing a three
there's something on the screen there's
something on the screen that will run
right there's something on the screen
yeah a home address
just keep watching just keep looking
you're signed in okay i'm signed in okay
here let me do it in blacks if you'd
like to take a few minutes
well there's no hand that's showing up
for me to click
there is something on the screen right
now whoa whoa whoa come on look how much
i got here wait point of order
ethan has someone helping because i'm
doing this insane puzzle that if i make
one misstep it undoes everything i did
clearly it's this mom is literally
attaching it she's literally attaching
an
image to an email okay wait so i'm sorry
a point of order overruled
okay so
send an email so how the hell am i
so i'm signed in
okay you were on the right track just
just keep looking at the screen you're
missing something very very critical
google your sign i'm signed in
okay maybe i should just put not now
okay not now
okay now you need access ask for access
or switch wait
what are you on i don't know i just i
i push that
oh don't laugh
dad always says to me don't be afraid
you're in the nether world of the
google i guess okay it says request
access right i'm seeing now that you're
trying to get into google docs that's
not where you want to be that's not
working you need you need to go to you
need to go to the email service oh
lord what just happened so i'm missing
one and four one and four okay wait i
need access
for access or switch to an account with
access
yes
we're a little we're a little off the
beaten path here
okay i'm still signed in it says okay
but then i want to put not now
is this right here yeah
again the message option the issue is
that you're you're you're trying to get
into a document this you're not in the
email service at all right i've cleared
three squares for the record i've played
three
how are we are we as she logged into the
email successfully well she logged into
the account but i realized
she's not actually at the email service
she's trying to get it right okay
request access yeah that's not gonna
help
okay i'm gonna give you a hint i think
you logged into the wrong app yeah
you're you're you're trying to get
logged into the wrong app yes
you're going to want to go to gmail
google mail
ah
google
google search
google that might be a good that might
be a good place to start because then
you could search for okay google search
right so okay so you're on google now
that's good i have to look for something
which i have no idea how do i scroll
down it's called gmail
so you i don't know how to scroll down
well you don't you don't really have to
can i should i sign in
uh there's no there's a look there's a
might there's there's this thing
okay here wait i'm going to look for
gmail right
yeah there's a mail
right is that what i want that's that's
exactly what you want okay now uh
there's gmail
oh interesting all right website
you're in trouble mom
oh here we go gmail is an email that
invites
you're in trouble
wait a minute
temporary error
oh man you're in trouble oh lord i think
i think you just want to click on that
that big gmail link near the top the one
that's that's purple because it's been
visited
you know how to move the before i'm
moving the cursor i just don't know what
to do
well there's all kinds of gmail email
from google gmail that that seems
promising
sign in google account all right
wait what is this
create an account i have to create an
account oh my god mom
well i do see that this is more
challenging than i thought i thought
this one would be a layup for you
there is there is the ability to sign in
i see at the
we're out of there this is the hardest
thing i've ever done but let's see i
think i'm actually going to sign in
accounts
yeah
in order to oh see i'm back with the
dictionaries okay wait
oh pose what i don't know what you did
but this is it you're in you're in email
you're in okay so you're you're on the
final phase now now you just need to i i
have to look for an attachment that says
donna's meme
do i want inbox
well you want to send oh so you want to
send me an email with this meme this
epic meme okay but i have it
send
right okay
and what does it say on the screen right
there
there's all kinds of things
does it say send two anywhere
well it says sent
inbox sentence sent is past tense
right drafts
do i want drafts uh i don't think you've
made any drafts at this point you you
you're you're starting that message send
send one now oh interesting
okay
yeah and that seems promising i'm
closing in and i'm dictionaries again oh
i wrote two seven i'm not sure why the
dictionary why does the dictionary thing
keep coming up
i don't know
new message okay here we go oh
so right okay there we go all right
three you're talking about might be in
trouble
go go go donna go oh my god
uh-huh at
uh-oh which has happened nine the nine
okay
right
they speed up as they go along though
because you have more to work off of so
you're pretty close oh it's just a three
here
hurry dot com how are you making oh [ __ ]
i'm oh my god this is we're in the final
phase here you you got to jam you got to
jam ethan okay the subject is do i have
to put the quotes or just can i put
donna put subject yeah
whatever you want
holy [ __ ] this is down to the wire donna
do i have to space it or is it oh no
don't worry about that don oops wait a
minute donna there was no
there was no requirement in the
challenge for the the subject
or you don't need a subject
i see what's happening
oops wait a minute
i understand what's happening now oh
okay
now in
so it looks like you've sent an email um
i'm gonna look in my email right now
and see if i received it
which is located on this and um yeah
there is no attack
oh my god she sent the so she she sent
the email but she did not send the
attachment she she wow this is close she
made clothes
ethan she made the subject line of the
email the name of the file that would
happen yeah
donna meme jpeg
that's pretty amazing that's a boomerang
wait a minute back to the dictionary
okay focus ethan i'm not losing this
wait sounds like something
in the subject forward
send
no you're not sending anything oh
dan i think you you might want to just
start from scratch on on the sending
side because you you sent an email but
it did not have the attachment that we
that we need so
well how do i get the damn attachment
well drafts
um well no
so you can attach you can attach
something to an email wait but i don't
know where the where the
what is this make unread
yeah archive yeah i i don't think that's
gonna help you
i don't think any of those buttons at
the top are going to help you you might
want to take a look at the buttons at
the bottom though the buttons at the
bottom okay maybe more helpful to you
formatting oh here attachment oh
okay so
i want to go to documents
no i don't like it it says on the paper
top it says on the paper where it is
desktop
okay
and then there's this
that
so now i have to send it or no i have to
attach it that's right
so how the hell do i attach it
well damn
well you're seeing it on the screen
right you see it right there this one do
i open it so maybe maybe click on it
first
it's nothing's happening well i can see
your mouse and you're you're not
clicking on it i did it
oh ethan's done
i did it you cheated oh stop it mom had
to okay so should i help you now
complete it here i'll help you we're
very close wow i did it i can't believe
i won i cannot believe i could this was
very hard for me i know a lot of you
sudoku fans will probably laugh at me
but this i would have rather have done
that you cheated
okay stop okay so what what am i doing
wrong
oh is she on the attachment window yeah
yeah wow yeah we're we're pretty close
we're back double click the diamond
double click or just click it or just
even one click would would be okay
okay there it is yeah that's the
attachment
my mom said follow your dreams so i ran
over the neighbor's dog
[Laughter]
no you want to click open
okay
where do i do that though the button
that says open
there's a button that says open there is
it's not on the image itself that
wouldn't make sense right
start a new one nope
open here it is excellent
you don't have to click so hard either
oh god okay so now now i have to say now
the thing is yeah we've we've
i don't know
oh uh oh yeah
you have not entered the oh my god
what's with the dictionary
i have no idea i've never had that
problem
you have to put in the recipient
right right now it's not being sent to
anyone so oh i thought i already sent it
to you
well you sent me something but it wasn't
the right thing so
right now
definition of recipient right there no i
don't before
his email address in the recipient line
oh
yeah okay so now i have to send it to
dan that's right
dan
look you already sent me one so it's
giving you a suggestion you don't have
to type the whole thing out you could
just click my uh my little face right
there okay right here uh-huh just click
that okay
there you go she clicks so hard like
every click
is such an ordeal and uh oh and now i
have to just send it you're pretty much
good to go at this point oh
did it go looks like you completed your
i i i think
i'm checking my inbox
right now
at the moment i am not i'm not seeing
any oh there it is
i gotta say mom i didn't i had more
faith in you on that case
to send an email
it's pretty amazing you almost i know
how to send emails well the i beg to
differ she's not used to using apple
products yeah i've never used
she's not used to using apple and
there's a big difference i mean we're
not talking about uh
she's picked up grandma eileen's mantle
of being technologically challenged
okay
i think if i was more familiar with the
apple products it might have been easier
your hair
cause i use damn what's your take you've
witnessed it do you buy the apple excuse
me well right right out of the gate she
somehow activated some sort of feature
which i is i i believe is an apple
feature to give the dictionary
definition of whatever word that she
clicks on and that was that was that was
uh that was causing a lot of apple and
i've never accidentally done that yeah i
don't know how to turn that i have a
skill for that
opening up the right one on who's the
boomer
yeah it's time it's a thai we're eating
all right
well
so ends our first episode of families
hey how was it
it was fun a lot of highs some lows some
goofs some gags it was fun some
embarrassing stories there was some
embarrassing stories
oh my god i hope no one's
never mind we hope no one's watching no
nobody's watching no i was going to say
something else but go ahead say it don't
say it end it off i was going to say i
hope my parents aren't watching but
now they're they're up and having going
what the hell's the matter with you
donna they're fuming they're fuming up
there my father's rolling in his grave
[Music]
[Applause]
that's embarrassing grandpa jerry's in
heaven being like i knew i didn't like
that gary
about the acid story too late
i know all right well let's see what
happens next week we don't know what's
gonna happen it could be my dad that
could be interesting
yeah it could be my mom again or it
could be nothing depending if you guys
hate it
your brother your sister right your son
right family oh yeah
be good
count to 10 and do the abcs he'll be
he'll be everything will be poop
what are you doing today poop
yep
well guys i hope you enjoyed let us know
what you think cheers you guys cheers it
was fun it was a lot of fun and uh we'll
see you guys on thursday for after dark
because it is my birthday this week and
we are taking a family vacation yes
happy birthday
thank you thank you thank you so we'll
see you guys on thursday for after dark
ciao
[Music]
you